I cannot wait any longer he is
officially here Kyle [ __ ] brand yes
in the building we swear on this day oh
yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah alright so I want to share
everything with the listeners out there
the homies the 33 percent okay I did not
want to meet you outside I wanted to
meet you in the studio because I've
spent the last few days watching
interviews of Dan Patrick watching
interviews like when you were promoting
your show man is just taking in all this
[ __ ] and I was like his energy is such
like mine that if I meet you I'm gonna
talk to you too much and wasted totally
started to do that right beforehand but
I'm excited I'm excited too I have to
start with a bone to pick with you
though I can I pick my bone first right
first of all you have me on shortly
thereafter Nate Burleson yeah and [ __ ]
you for doing that because I feel like
Jerry Stackhouse Jerry Stackhouse had to
dunk after Vince Carter in the dunk
contest it doesn't matter what he did he
wasn't gonna live up to it you and
Burleson are talking about
I gotta tear my muscles to build new
ones and very interesting than you're
rapping and I'm like how am I supposed
to come on after Nate's terrible it's
like watching somebody slay karaoke
they're like Kyle Kyle girl get up there
you're not you're screwed just walk out
you're a completely different energy and
complete an you were the Bill Belichick
Browns polo yeah which is this really
happened how many shirts do you have
because this is a thing for you and I
appreciate it I had a lot when I was
doing the show and I fell sure yeah I
just said um I want stuff that you see
it and immediately transports you so if
you got a picture of refrigerator Perry
and mr. T shaking hands in 1986 I want
that on a t-shirt if you have Dan Reeves
wearing a constable hat in London so
what you may do you make these t-shirts
yeah I make them all and the belly check
Cleveland Browns which to me is like
it's like DiCaprio and growing pains
like this really happened
we'll be listening to Mike Lombardi's
book today just on the train yeah cuz I
love football and he's talking about how
the last time they want to playoff game
was in 1994 and he's the head coach and
Nick Saban's on staff yeah Kirk Ferentz
and you go it's some curse of the
Bambino [ __ ] I know like they lose Babe
Ruth and he goes away but it's kind of
like Bill with the Browns it is I
thought about that I wasn't gonna save
my I was gonna say you know a bone to
pick with hit my bone left go come on
something happened two years ago that I
had waited my entire [ __ ] life for go
on the Eagles won the [ __ ] Super Bowl
I have spent my entire life suffering
through Rodney Peete getting hurt in the
playoffs - rich coat I being in my head
coach - Ronde Barber intercepting
Donovan AB - four straight NFC
championship games - losing the Patriots
of my quarterback vomiting and it was
the year where I'm in media and I'm like
I am gonna be the media member with the
Eagles and you do a [ __ ] underdog
rant and um I'm not gonna lie I'm a
combo'd you dude I literally was like
reading stuff about controlling the ego
because I'm sitting there going this
[ __ ] is getting all this eagles love
right now but I will say this when they
want it all of that went away and I said
I want to give this [ __ ] a hug
so I just want you to know though that
for like a three week span I was so
jealous you bro I get that a lot do you
really absolutely you know that when the
Bears win that Super Bowl if [ __ ]
Nick Wright like does a speech about the
Bears are my team yeah screw you Pete
Prisco I was born in Chicago actually
felt very cathartic for me so thank you
for letting me keep let it all out
the thing that I get a lot is see y'all
bro you're from Philly right you grew up
in Philly I said not only did I not grow
up there at the time when I did said
Rance I think I had benefit all Fiat two
times in my life in both times it was to
play football at Franklin Field in
college and get my ass kicked by Penn so
if anything I hated Philadelphia I was
not the native son the prodigal son any
of it
but I'm at the parade I tweet with the
players
right I'm gonna share something with
your at the parade and you'd like an
allocated spot I'm at the parade with a
Reggie white long-sleeved sweater with a
with a daddy cigar in my mouth and a
bottle of [ __ ] bourbon in my pocket
because for me it was like I'm
unleashing everything right now yeah and
I I will say it has it been cool to be
embraced by a city that's not your own
like that it's gotta be crazy it's
unbelievable especially like it
specially that city with respect to any
but you know Denver San Francisco
they're all fine
like Philadelphia's a special breed I
was prepared to give a very very tough
and I mean that day that parade I was
offered beers joints pills favors I mean
anything people there's people of been
there like 12 hours when I got there to
the front row they were like we love you
you want this this is my girl whatever
you need I'm good I'm serious that
actually happened I'm believing it I'm
not even gonna dispute this I mean
Kelsey tore the roof off I know I was
standing there a hundred feet from that
when that all happened it was really
really cool I mean that that morning and
I'm just name-dropping I'm just resting
tonight that morning I know you flash
like I'm trying to did I'm good are you
I know I'm embracing you as part of this
now that we've met and now they were ya
know all I need to say was that oh it
sucked for a little bit and now I'm good
that's how I live my life what's funny
though about the Philly thing is that
the common tweet that I would get
constantly for Philly fans you'll never
buy a beer in this town again you'll
never buy a never buy a beer not long
after Super Bowl six months later my
wife my wife and my two kids and I we
took a trip to Philadelphia just as a
tourist see the Liberty Bell on that
ship history is unbelievable that night
the kids go to bed I go down to the
corner liquor stores to buy a six-pack
like for my wife and I to drink with
watch a movie I am standing in line at
this corner store in front of like three
Eagles fans like Dawkins Jersey
sweatshirt hood it out the back I'm
carrying a six-pack of Yingling because
winnin race is that moment the moment
I'm not making this up this dude in
front of me turns around and he goes yo
you're Kyle Brandt's the Eagles red guy
oh I love you take a picture of me
selfie selfie selfie and then as we're
wrapping up he goes hey what do you got
there man I go oh it's just six-pack he
goes
cool enjoy nice to meet you walked out
of there
didn't buy anything that was the moment
I paid for the beer in that town two
minutes after and I just laughed about I
think I thought about it he said Oh
yelling oh yeah nice see you later man
take care that was the moment that's
incredible that's awesome
that's filling uh man all right I have a
lot of things we're gonna get into I
want to talk some football in the
beginning sure just to conversation
lubricant before I like dive into your
past you're you're a really hard person
to prepare an interview for because
you've lived so many lies yeah and each
of those lives can take us down a
wormhole you can go down the days of our
lives Werner Hall you can go down the
Jim Rome wormhole so that's what I want
to talk NFL first because each of those
could be crazy I mean we name them as in
real world I mean come on that's what
I'm like there's so many
I know Ruthie and puck I can get you on
the phone right now I'm a very valuable
guest all right well the first thing I
want to do is major [ __ ] NFL news
happen yesterday major yeah the Oakland
Raiders are the Hard Knocks team heroin
for me for everyone that said wait till
next year where they're traveling I say
this to you you cannot risk it if this
team goes to the playoffs and you don't
get them next year also [ __ ] teams
moving we've seen this on Hard Knocks I
don't need to see the equipment guys
packing up [ __ ] I want to see Antonio
Brown walking in with no shirt but eight
change yes
so you're as equally excited as I can't
I didn't think we're gonna get it
I kept thinking they're gonna do us with
Detroit they're gonna do us they're not
gonna give us what we want they're gonna
give us Arizona and do Cuyler and
clinical care not it I had to talk about
the Arizona Cardinals for six straight
weeks leading up to the draft
it wasn't compelling no one gave a [ __ ]
no sorry I like Cuyler and all them you
don't care this is the goods and I
always think of it like if you consume
HBO like I'm sure you do
one of my favorite moments and all their
programming is right before you get the
oh they give you that what to expect in
this episode like graphic content
graphic language extreme violence yes I
feel like the Raiders Hard Knocks is
gonna be loaded with they're gonna need
all of those there's only like two and
you're like oh mild nudity what the hell
am i watching this show for but when
they hit you with like six of them
you're like this is about to be an
episode I feel like this
is gonna have all six of the other thing
that I love is Liev Schreiber who adds
so I had my friend david ingram create
some scripts for you because i know you
do this yes so i want you to do a little
bit of leave Liev Schreiber okay ah but
just wait for the music okay yes okay
okay though hold the hole I'm starting
it over all right there Schreiber is the
star of every season everyone
nevermind Antonio Brown it's Liev okay
folks a tree that symbolizes strength
terminus but this season the shade
provided by the mighty oak be dwarfed by
a shadow the size of the Las Vegas Strip
Antonio Brown or as he's known around
the NFL a bee must learn the ABCs of
Gruden's o FF e n s E or oMG or he'll be
out of the jo B it's catchy prose Jon
Gruden derives a practice straight from
the very Supercuts barbershop where mark
Davis's famous Bowl hairstyle was born
but those follicles won't be the only
cuts made at this facility by the end of
the week oh this is good
slow motion sprinkler head shot ankles
being taped and did you Tom do you see
what you just did yes you began thinking
of the images I have some left Co lakhs
of images that I can guarantee okay at 3
to 1 we are going to see video of
LaMarcus Joyner telling Jeff Fischer
that he's thinking about quitting the
Rams from hard knocks two years ago and
then showing LaMarcus Joyner as a leader
of the defense that's three to one
they're gonna do a Hard Knocks recap
back to LaMarcus join time stamped from
two years ago you started with LaMarcus
join that's kind of a deal cut I like it
these are locks lock number two we're
going to see van tez BER fix hit on
Antonio Brown directly before we see a
shot of the two of them walking up to
each other to start a practice it's you
don't know how they're gonna react but
then they're gonna DAP each other up and
it's gonna be really suspense but then
they'll DAP so the juxtaposition that's
at four to one okay
this is my number one the block I'm so
excited about but I'm also guaranteed
the Mona Lisa of images we are gonna see
Mark Davis with a hard hat on in Las
Vegas in Las Vegas he's gonna have a
bowl cut with a hard hat on overseeing
the Vegas stadium it's in an open field
and they'll be just some extraneous
pointing and nice some blueprints do you
think do you think the hard hat will be
raiders branded Oh for generic it will
be a black hard hat of the Raiders logo
logo I'm harden a thousand percent oh
that's so good I want on that action
I am also I'm hoping to see this if you
haven't read the article about Mark
Davis that came out about two years ago
apparently multiple times a week he goes
to a PF Changs near his house yep and he
sits at the end of the bar and he just
lays out newspapers and iced coffee and
when someone calls an s square he is he
says I'm in my office and then looks at
the bartender goes gets him every time
he says it every [ __ ] time
I need that [ __ ] killer line I need that
I think also relating to the PF Changs
at about a hundred to one
I think Schreiber will hit us with and
Mark Davis's new wide receiver Antonio
Brown is much like his pork both sweet
and sour and then they're off and
running I think we're gonna get a pork
joke based on firstly I've Shriver 100
to 1 I have a left go lock parlay these
are different images you will see during
hard knocks at two to one showing
Gruden's alarm clock and/or the clock in
his car image number two at three-to-one
Gruden's office light on from the
outside with every other office off
image number three at five to one Gruden
in his office under a spotlight like a
[ __ ] film noir holding a clicker just
it's the only thing on his office is a
beam of light so the whole parlay 72/1
pretty good you need all of those you
gotta hit all three of those images a
clock in the car or at the house him
sitting in a silhouette and then an
outside shot of a darkened building with
one lit office okay I'm gonna add a
couple okay I think that the shot of the
alarm clock I think it will be
it'll end in a 59 unlikely and I'll tell
you why that's people who are wake up
snobs I get up really early but I no
wake up snobs and I know this guy once
who said I set my alarm for 359 so I can
tell people I wake up before 4 a.m. that
slight little thing things me 59 I also
think that there's gonna be him and mike
Mayock standing in front of that depth
chart both hands on the hips right sigh
and then in to fade it in next week on
hard knocks hands on the hip side for
both of them in the 359 alarm you are
all over this you know this show well
alright I also have two awards and I
want you to know I want your input my
first one is I have three candidates for
the Bob Wiley award which is the most
unexpected coaching star number three
special teams coach Ritz Passat eeeh he
was with Gruden in Tampa Bay okay super
character I've met him before
he's like an Italian joke artist he's
Arthur's okay number two strength
trainer deuce Cruden John's son that's
why he's number two but my number one is
actually underrated defensive line coach
Brent's and Buckner if you watched all
or nothing with the Arizona Cardinals he
was the star of that one and it's his
first year there and they have to
replace Khalil Mac so I feel like
they're gonna be with him with Cleland
Farrell a lot like giving speeches yeah
but I'm curious what happens with deuce
on this show the son of the coach it
could get weird
there is usually that I love this top
because there is the breakout star that
you would never expect and like that is
all HBO shows if it's if it's bran from
Game of Thrones or anybody Paulie
walnuts from The Sopranos
but also I think in reality shows like
that Kristin Cavallari thing like Cutler
is the breakout star um I think it's the
fascinating thing here and I think the
dus grood and I don't know what his rap
is I don't know but puts 6000 pounds on
the hip sled and he'll put it up and I'm
in he that he's dwarfs the players so
everyone won't say anything in the
interviews about his dad you know what I
mean maybe revealing like what it's like
to grow up Gruden that type of thing
I would think so I would rowing up
Gruden sounds really isn't that good Jay
comes in visits and he's drunk in the
corner and every
Jay Gruden was awesome on this yours is
a [ __ ] lunatic yes and exactly look
at the size of the hog on your dad I
don't know where he got that I didn't
have that wit was it must have been
switched at birth
I mean he'll have jokes like that the
Gruden family I'll make muscles around
the Charles James Award for the most
unexpected player star number three
we're gonna get a lot of Hunter Renfro
though really white wide receiver from
Clemson Olli has a 42 year old stepdad
yeah he's the hair issue and it looks
like a substitute teacher stepdad dad
gum it up excitedly at this practice
that'll be a good one let's remember OHS
the guy your mom is dating right new in
your life and he brings you I have
something for that my number two
Jonathan Abram our favorite player on
this show I am rooting for him from the
time he gets drafted until now Jonathan
Abram is gonna talk his way and number
one Josh Jacobs the running bet that
they're gonna make a movie after he
lived in his car and yeah yeah there HBO
is gonna try and do that movie in this
show you know what you're right
they're gonna try and do it I'll tell
the story yes because we had him on the
show too and when every single time I'm
sure he's told in every interview it's
fantastic it's believable I know and HBO
they always have a heart in this Hard
Knocks it's not always just about
swearing and no Gunther Cunningham
there's always that really special
little Chronicle member last year it was
the the tight end that had the crystals
whose dad was having like constant heart
attacks they spent more on that than
anybody else the entire time that was
the star gents but they find it I just
it's surreal to me that we're actually
getting this like I remember like
struggling through the Dave Campbell
Cowboys and Marvin Lewis or bills or
something it's just like there this is
the one we've been waiting for all these
years you know I mean not only here like
I Rex Ryan Jets was great I mean it's
been amazing so good that kind of
brought it back I just if they realize
there's so much content give us more
episodes I know don't just sit on same
as Game of Thrones six episodes give us
yeah man I wish we could do it that's
why the all-or-nothing people love
because it's the whole season but that
ain't the home box office I was dated so
many alright so you mentioned stepdads
yeah I have one I do not know I do I've
been doing that oh you are very
qualified for this then okay I've been
doing something each week a different
quarterback rankings so when the
beer-chugging thing happened
I ranked him 1 through 32 Kirk Cousins
was last then last week I did if you put
all of the NFL quarterbacks into a
Hunger Games how would they fit I love
this
I had Carson Wentz number one being the
hunter last I had Marcus Mariota
because I don't even if he's athletic
enough to survive I think he got guys
can't we stop this and he done got it
out this week okay I am doing NFL
quarterback stepdad rankings as in which
quarterback would you most want to be
your stepdad if you got one I already
know my one I'm not gonna perfect don't
say yeah my my producer David Engler
that you know very well yeah Harvard
said that there's three considerations
that we must have they must treat your
mom great they won't try to replace dad
and they'll take you on some fun day
trips yes that sounds good my two early
favorites I'm gonna give you mine first
I want to hear yours okay my two early
on favorites are Marcus Mariota because
I believe he's an incredible stepdad
he'd go listen to your mother he'd step
back he get trips to Hawaii it's pretty
great
the other one is Russell Wilson and the
main reason is we're seeing him do it
already he's an amazing stepdad right
now for a future son Wow and think about
it he's cool he's he wants to do
anything he shows up to ballet those are
my two early favorites you apparently
have a different one
I do like Mariota because also there's a
consideration of like this man is he's
been intimate with my mother and you'd
want someone who's a gentleman yeah you
want someone who's gentle have to be a
gentleman yeah like you know there's
some guys I don't want it to be they
might be unranked I know yeah I'm not
gonna say their names because whole
thing um I give me fitzpatrick man that
was and respect he said Ryan Fitzpatrick
that's Rick been through it all bad
jokes
cool beard little mess with you a little
bit but he'll also teach you a few
things he basically is a stepdad right
now for Josh Rosen okay he'll give you
your first Coors original bank bracket
for a nice crispy boy if you need to
smoke a little J he'll give you that I
think Fitzpatrick has been at all I love
that guy I mean Phil Rivers is an
interesting one because it's a father to
many but this is the thing I think it
was not just about the dad
yeah if Phillip Rivers becomes your
stepdad you now have nine siblings
I don't need that that's what I'm saying
no I'm so Philip Rivers oh he's great
yeah but guess what now I have nine
brothers and sisters yeah and that'll
never do it because the art of being a
stepdad is you have to know your
boundaries like I'm kind of this kid's
dad but not really so Rivers has always
been the dad he's the Alpha Fitzpatrick
is gonna back up on 52 yeah back up step
down as you're the backup so well now
Brady know his boundaries with you or
are you getting a kiss smack on the lips
that's something you need to factor
along too passionate kiss no yeah I mean
I'll take it but I'll take a kiss I'm
listening Brady right now
Hoyer would be a good stepdad all the
backups so be grateful your time so
starting quarterbacks with backup
experience that's interesting
yeah because Kirk Cousins the problem
there is you're gonna get so many
speeches Kyle have you heard of the
phrase compound interest
fucking-a leave me ho C Kirk Cousins is
arguably my favorite quarterback in the
league as a character I love Kirk
Cousins as a character pebbles and
Counting life and immortality
just like he wears crow keys on a
sunglasses and like the zinc oxide on
his nose
he's a fanny pack I love it's very
stepdad he is he's 30 going on like 46
every suburban dad and he's aware of it
yeah I'm interested in your beer
chugging rankings because 32 you think
he's slower than all those yeah at Eli
at 31 and then I had the guys that I
know like don't drink beer like Mariota
doesn't drink down well there's
Christians - they're probably on course
you're like Derek Carr was like 27 for
me you know what's fascinating
I had Eli way up at oh I just did that
to [ __ ] with you like I said man yeah
man breeze of frat boys I look anyway
I'm sure you could put it down yes as a
competitor drew brees would be a great
stepdad though yeah I would he's doing a
thing now I posted on Instagram where
he's showing all his boys the classic
sports movies and like it's kind of
pissing me off wait Adam you are you
father I'm not okay I am a father of two
and it's my five-year-old son doesn't
want to watch anything I want to watch
doesn't care wants to watch crap on
YouTube and everything breeze is like
he's supposed to news Graham just shown
my boys it field of dreams and Hoosiers
I'm like your kids are watching that at
it incredibly he's like now I'm gonna
show them Rocky
the original Rocky is not an easy watch
it's very entertaining it's slow is out
and this kids are like yeah we like it
it's like Scrooge
Brees how are you that good of a dad
that your kids can actually sit through
that stuff how old your oldest five yeah
but when did it hit you when did sports
hit you it I began to understand it at
like seven or eight yeah like my dad
says that was a time where I looked at
an Eagles game and I said who's 57 and
he went oh you're into it mm-hmm like
that's when it hit me 85 Bears for me I
mean I grew up in Chicago so you know
like six or seven yeah and the fridge
was like there's made for kids it was
like the perfect introduction to
football football was a kid in the
fridge and he was in GI Joe that was my
grind was seven it was the wild thing
Mitch Williams come on you 1930 Phillies
and it was the mullets like that was the
team that got me to love sport how did
Joe Carter make you feel about sports
that was you know that was the first
time I cried because of sports
I had my babysitter there is that right
I don't know where my parents were right
I know my dad went to a game in Toronto
that series and got a ball signed by the
fanatic
oh no kidding and that's the signature
it was like the best thing ever
we got understands the guy who grew up
in Philadelphia born and raised on
Michelle Adelphia I love the fanatic
Mitch Williams nails dikes those are my
guys in Philly Lenny Dykstra was my guy
so where you was Walter was sweetness
you're number one yeah it was a little
cutie like a Jim McMahon guy Big Time
punky cubillas my first Halloween
costume number nine the you know very
sunglasses sunglasses and then you find
come to find out there was all these
urban myths about why he had the
sunglasses and he's even said it I
stabbed myself in the eyeball with a
fork the story is he had a knot he was
playing cowboys and Indians and he had
like a holster something and he was
trying to get a knot out of the strings
you went got a fork like a kid would and
put it in and tried to pull it out and
then stabbed himself in a kunai ball man
and that's why I always wear sunglasses
that's that's the story from the punk
EQB himself perfect quarterback for
Buddy Ryan and Mike Ditka
can you imagine fect imagine there's so
much eighty-five nostalgia right now cuz
the Bears just had their whole deal yes
I think it's kind of lost on us to
someone like in the media now that the
Chicago Bears dropped a music video
before the playoffs began about how
we're gonna win the Super Bowl
yeah can you imagine if the Browns did
that this year anybody the reaction that
would be and the takes they did it and
then they shut out the first two games
and won the Super like five touchdowns
was Mike I feel that way about also the
current
BA in the current NFL or certain things
that the NFL if it just doesn't get the
same attention I know you know like levy
on bail just dropped a rap album no and
no one gave up yeah it's fine
and he said out of year and was like oh
whatever back then that [ __ ] was
incredible wait
you're you have an obsession with one
player I have an obsession with Brian
Dawkins that the one time I did meet him
I freaked out and I told him that he was
all of my passwords on all of my
computers cuz that's where I was like
dock 20 or something oh my screen my a I
am a screen name was docked for MVP that
was yeah that was my life away message I
hear you that you have that with Deion
Sanders yeah I I once I was with my dad
in 1991 and we went to New Orleans
because we were going to the Sugar Bowl
which was the Rick Meyer Notre Dame
versus Shane Matthews Florida Gators my
dad's an Irish alum so I grew up Notre
Dame we were there a week early for
vacation and there just happened to be a
playoff game that day it was the
wild-card round Falcons versus the
Saints and I went and Deon had an
interception and he lateraled it and
like this is you could maybe understand
this I know I can for me this white kid
from the suburbs to see this athlete
with the long legs and the chains and
the bandanna it was the coolest thing I
had ever seen a jheri curl yeah that it
wasn't like um it wasn't easy for me or
Tupac or anything like Deon was my I
felt like brought me into hip-hop and
being like the coolest athlete of all
time and after I dropped a bandana
playing football because of him right
wore a bandana into my totes my coach
told me to take that [ __ ] off or you're
off the team
I used to try to wear one under my
baseball hat even in Little League I had
every one of his jerseys I mean that
includes like the Redskins Jersey the
Cincinnati Reds Jersey I had all of them
as obsessed and I still have not met
Deon even though we work on the same
network and I kind of don't want it's
never happened I've been to tables over
from and he said here have a cup of
coffee by himself you know why it's I
believe in that don't meet your heroes
thing man I have you met anyone that's
really disappointed you you've been in
this business for a long time and you
were on the Jim Rome show which was like
you guys talked to [ __ ] everyone you
mean everybody especially radio ro Super
Bowl you're there there's this one we're
gonna balance
sit out give me I'll do it too so that
you not on this island I got one that
does one that disappointed you and that
one that like really pleasantly
surprised you alright well I mean the
one that disappointed me I can't say his
name mine was Dan Marino disappointed
you yes why because I grew up on a spin
Chara Dan Marino I I thought who are you
yes and it there's some times where
people walk in and they they act like
you're a burden and I'm like you're
being paid to be here right now like and
so for me it was like the whole energy
and then there was a second time where I
met him and it was the same thing and so
for me it was like I also donovan mcnabb
'he's up there with me to dominate was
when i was like 14 15 years old and it
was after a I sent the Sixers to the
championship and he wouldn't give me an
autograph and as a kid that [ __ ] you up
is it hard being a Philly sports fan in
your relationship with Donovan up to
including this minute I mean it's been
difficult I I think it's so much more
in-depth it's so much about race in
Philadelphia it's a lot about that era
it's a lot about the fact that t/o came
in and put a spotlight on him about how
he wasn't real you know you have t oh
this unabashed truth teller and Donovan
that goes I don't talk about [ __ ] and
tío said well the reason you don't talk
about [ __ ] is because you're playing the
company line and the city split at that
moment and I was a Tioga I mean I'm a
big deal guy - I just like McNabb he's
from Chicago Mount Carmel everything he
was like Destin do great things and run
the country whatever a really bright
future football was football and now
it's like the duis and like he's talking
to TMZ sports about how he should be in
the Hall of Fame and I feel like Donovan
you're better than Swarek it should have
gone better than that um alright so I
got your answer alright so I have to
couch it I'm a huge an ironic
unapologetic fan of Guy Fieri huge fan
Guy Fieri as he pronounces it I I loved
Triple D it's my escapism on a Friday I
sit down a poor a huge martini at the
end of the week and I watch him eat
garbage if they asked you to do a guest
episode you that would be such an honor
I love that show it's a great show I
love it I got to meet guy after years of
watching it and we had gone back and
forth little because he was a Raiders
fan
to meet him in a suite at the Super Bowl
this is the Eagles Patriots Super Bowl a
couple ago and I was really excited and
he was really cool to me and my wife was
there and guy works a little blue or a
lot at least that day and there were a
bunch of jokes which I liked that like I
think that my wife was like I think I'm
gonna give some you back a texture it
was it was about my endowment and all
that time I was like I'm into that guy
but like this is my wife and she was
just gone so I'm sure if you heard that
it'd be very embarrassed but since then
whenever I do Triple D I'm at home now
Brook has to like go watch something
else which I'm here for the dick jokes
fine I'll make it myself but like
there's the first meeting with my wife
maybe that's how it's like expecting
Danny Tanner but instead you're getting
the full-fledged joke Sam Kinison you
know I'm saying it was the real thing
what's amazing about that is when you
meet Guy Fieri you expect him to be the
jovial like Bam Bam Bigelow clothes
wearing like friendly guy but he in his
mind as a superstar yeah and I've seen
him walk into clubs in LA where Travis
Scott is on stage and James Harden's got
a table and guy Ferry walked through and
he thinks he's bigger than both of them
and and it's to me it's hilarious but I
guess he really is because people were
[ __ ] freaking out with Guy Fieri they
want a piece of him he just got a star
on the Walk of Fame and the full
discloser
I was just texting with Guy Fieri the
other day oh you I swear to God and
because I saw that he has a star and I
just said dude I'm proud of you
congratulations text me right back on or
not you know you want a funny thing
about guy and I know that everyone has
opinions about that so one time it's
incredible and it's fee Eddie Yeti one
time he called me and cuz he had been on
the show and he said I heard it was
great and left me a voicemail call me
back so I called guy and what's so funny
is that he still has one of those ring
backs remember ring back no we're
instead what song did he pick please
hold while your party is reached and
it's just no no [ __ ] it would say it
would say I would say it would say
something to the effect of while you
wait for like Kyle enjoy this song and
it would be like Chamillionaire do you
do what
knowing guy and guys
met him what do you think the song it
was not born to be wild
it was ac/dc back in black dance Dan an
ant Dan and then it just ends Kyle and
it's so funny here's what even better
this is what a superfan
I saved his number in my phone and in
the listing in my phone I got all the
little emojis I have a little red car
and then like a burger and a french fry
and a beer and like all of like what you
know Triple D stuff and every once in a
while will text and I'm still a huge fan
but he has the back and black ring back
it was so cool I was so so that's right
anytime isn't that that's guy so I was
talking before about how you've lived so
many lives the reason that I appreciate
you and I appreciate Nate so much is
that both of you can really do anything
and my struggle as I've kind of come
through this business is I never knew
how to like people be like well what do
you do I know I be like I [ __ ] do
everything what do you want to do I know
you go I don't know I haven't I don't
know if it exists yet I know like people
ask you that question all the time and I
feel like I gave a terrible answer you
supposed to you know you get taught you
gotta have your elevator speech
in 20 seconds should be able to say
exactly what I do with your life and
people say somebody you're in a maybe in
a room of someone have influenced or
you're doing a work meeting so what do
you want to do what do you wanna do in
five years and I always feel like my
answer is terrible meandering and slow I
was I was emailing once with Bill
Simmons when he was putting together the
ring tour and I grew up Simmons like I'm
a massive fan and I think he asked me a
straight-up question about would he like
what do you want to do in five years
where do you see yourself and I said
this to him on his podcast my answer was
so pretentious and pathetic I was like I
think I was like 35 at the time and I'm
like well you know I want to be the
voice of the 30 something year old man
in America and that's how I said that it
was like what kind of douchebag says
about himself but he's like now is a
good answer he lied but like I feel like
I do have trouble answering that's quite
hard and it's so egotistical with me
because the reason I have trouble
answering because I just have so many
skills I don't know where to put them
that's a lie
but you struggle with it too I think
it's because the main thing is the
difference between producing and being
on camera oh God because on camera gives
you that rush
where you're performing but you're also
it's like it feels good to get it out
but also you're just like talking and
like having a good conversation but the
producing aspect of it they're sitting
in a room and coming up with ideas and
coming up with concepts and building a
show and stacking a run down and landing
that interview like that [ __ ] feels
[ __ ] good too and I think one makes
the other so much better and I can see
when I watch good morning football your
influence I can feel it like I know a
Jim Rome bit type of thing that I used
to listen to thanks good morning
football like I can see it that that's
why I think it's hard to pick one side
it is there there is a really sweet
satisfaction from being in that
production side and like a specific
example will be let's say you're having
a guest come on whatever show you're
producing and you were a charge of
coming up with the questions when the
host asked your question and gets a
great reaction from the guest it's a
high it's a natural high I mean I
remember one time Ronda Rousey on the
way up when she was just blowing up and
just starting to tap chicks out all the
time
I there was a question I found deep deep
deep in her Twitter feed about how she
was way into candy crush or something I
guess candy crush was on the way up to
and Jim asked her this question about
candy crush and she like exploded
laughing it was clearly taken aback that
in all these interviews she had done no
one had asked her that and I felt like I
got a natural high from them yeah I
really really did and I don't know if
someone watching it understands what
that's like but it really is cool so my
history with Jim Rome my first job out
of college was in Hastings Nebraska so
this is 2008 to 2010 this is years like
two to four of you be I was with Romney
officer yeah and there was no local talk
radio and if there was all they were
talking about was Nebraska football and
I couldn't handle it so the only station
I had that was national was some Fox
regional that got Jim Rohn right and I
had no idea what the [ __ ] I was
listening to from those first two months
they throw me a vine like karma and then
I heard the smack off and I said I said
this is my entrance into media and I
would sit in my living room as a news
general assignment news reporter in
Nebraska and I would write down
my smack offtake was gonna be okay and I
sat there and I was and I never [ __ ]
called but it was my plan all along was
to be the JT the brick-like come in
there applanation I just destroy the
[ __ ] smack from Hastings never a
thing do you look back and regret though
um you planned the call and you had your
angle and you're sure you would have
been great yeah why did you never call I
don't know dad did you ever happen did
you ever really pick up the phone dial
just I think I died and it was like a
busy signal a few times I was just like
there's a sign yeah I was like it's just
not gonna happen and I was like you know
what like let me focus on getting out of
Nebraska first and I'll just do this the
right way I'm not gonna I wonder it cuz
you know but I'll back off
they've it's propelled them into actual
careers and jobs and jate see the bricks
perfect example if you were to call them
one the smack off you would have been on
the map and then you would've been a
thing I would have I did not have the
tools back then you didn't think you're
that winning call no no I look back then
and I know I didn't I was nowhere take
your son in 2008 was like Lindsey Vonn
and Bo Pelini I so you know my rap cast
and all that so I know it well so just
like you do with highlights where you
would weave in I just took so many
references from the show like rachet
Caldwell's
eyes great like that and I just every
[ __ ] line was one so I built it this
is great
ya just never [ __ ] happened I gotta
give you credit for those casts the web
cast a little bit now and do I like them
I feel like we've ripped them off we do
them on Good Morning football I I got a
chance to host Rome's TV show on CBS
Sports Network when he was out once you
did like a han Solo thing I did you
really did look me up yeah I did the Han
Solo but and another thing I did what
you did we mention in as many times as
possible but my brilliant idea so I
thought was I weaved in as many sports
blogs as possible so that I thought they
would pick it up and do a blog on it
which they sort of did yeah but that
[ __ ] was so good man and I had the one
for me it wasn't the wrap cast it was
the wrestle cast and you start off and I
like it's so funny and so time stamp
that you're doing Teddy Bridgewater
College highlights yes and I remember
listening to it it was like all right
you start off he's the ultimate warrior
or what a macho man all right those are
entry-level and then you said the
defense it should Coco beware and now we
got something and then when we got to
dunk the cloud I'm like this guy's
playing on a different
I really thought they were cool I'm
sorry I mean that well the funny thing
is is anytime someone does it now I my
Twitter mentions blow up yeah also
there's this one website called like
hip-hop XL that like every two months
it's like crazy white people do in the
news that did rap rap and I'm always
number one there and so people are like
oh [ __ ] I didn't know you were this guy
yeah I get that throat a lot of what is
the go-to white person rap reference i I
think it's 99 problems but
something-something isn't one like white
people say like get off your shoulder or
add is that have a word that's one thing
there's always very problematic for a
very long time everything
turn-of-the-century to a tough time for
shizzle my drizzle yeah there's so much
of that stuff mm-hmm dan there are so
many 99 problems but a black but it's
it's it's a it's a Gary Payton I will
you pass to Sean camp it's the easiest
thing to finish my biggest question
about your career is your trajectory was
going in one direction so [ __ ] hard
real world into acting an on camera and
then you hit the emergency brakes so
[ __ ] hard and went and became a
producer on the Jim Rome show I've heard
the stories he reached out to Ross
Tucker Ross Tucker said no you gotta
check out my guy in California he's a
little different but check him out
I've read that you were you or I was
watching that you were going on all
these auditions for all these movies and
you kind of thought you had a chance for
Knight Rider was it yeah they were doing
a Knight Rider reboot with a new car it
lasted like five seconds and I advanced
a couple of times anyway this is gonna
be and when that fell through the last
night the whole time though were you
wanting to work in sports was it like
that was the calling or you just knew
that acting wasn't gonna be the sauce
for you
I think Sports is like the back-up plan
like they say you know look Robin
Williams just always say learned it's a
dig ditches like because your acting is
not gonna work out like sports was the
back-up plan I what I want it to be the
movie star I want it to be Matt Damon
all of that things and then you know at
the end of the soap opera here's what
happens you do a cited a surprise for
three and a half years and everybody
leaves
at least once to try to become the movie
star and I left and I just it just never
ever happened and you start you're not
making any money and the checking
balance just goes down down down down
down until I heard from Rome unsolicited
my rock bottom wasn't even Knight Rider
it was I got a job hosting some sort of
weird infomercial and I'm not making
this up with Jose Canseco and he came in
on his motorcycle with his girlfriend
and we were Hawking products like a GPS
system that goes on your motorcycle and
a golf ball tracker and I was like I had
I have an education like I wouldn't want
my doing here when I was they Canseco
Friday and I think I mean like $1,000
maybe for like a two-day shoot just
terrible
that's not like I got to reevaluate this
thing it's not working Wow
yeah I mean it's yeah you've heard this
I just I started one to the Playboy
Mansion a lot which sounds really cool
but like I felt like a loser
like a douche really I mean that and
what way it's cool to go to the Playboy
Mansion once it is you grow up hearing
the stories and Charlie Sheen and James
Caan like to start going time after time
after time again I was just the first
time you're like this is magical I made
it I'm gonna tell all my friends this is
unbelievable there's the Corrado and
there's the the monkey cage and this is
where I heard this happened and there
used to be a pile of blow here and this
actors I made it but then you get to the
point where as you walk up to the bar
the bartender already knows your drink
order cuz you've been there so many
times I mean how many times can you
belly up with Adrian Grenier
and Bill Maher and Craig Kilborn and
Pauly Shore it's like it's the same crew
every single time and I still feel like
this is pathetic I don't even have a job
even these people are all very
successful in their doing and like I
don't have a job I barely have any money
I don't have a girlfriend I gotta do
something else it gets it gets pretty
lame I so I want to sit in a dark musty
radio room and produce sports talk like
that's the part that's it's such a
humbling reset it is like what were you
doing for the Jim Rose show in like the
first few months I mean I was doing a
lot of things that the most humbling is
like I was just above a call screener
and I mean there's respect call
screeners but it's a springboard to do
bigger things like I remember it was new
at the time that you could text the
radio show if you text 370 170 and I was
screening texts like you would come in
and someone would have a funny take on
I don't know whoever it may be Jake
Plummer and I would be like oh this is
great and I would hand at the room and
maybe he would read it maybe he wouldn't
and then in the morning you know I would
give him ideas about maybe we should
talk about Devin George and what he said
last night which sounds like a terrible
idea but that was the kind of stuff I
was coming up with but wake up at 4:00
in the morning drive from the valley in
Burbank 50 miles down to Orange County
where he works and then drive 50 miles
back single not a lot of money and like
super super humbled but I think it like
it cut a toughness groove in me I knew
and I got humbled big time when did that
when did did you ever do you remember
the moment where Jim kind of looked at
you and you're like I am gonna be a big
part of this guy show like it kind of
trained like yeah the first Duke who we
had was I had had a blog at the time
just when I was an unemployed act I kept
a blog that was a cool thing to do in
2007 and I wrote a blog once they used
to work out in the valley its valleys in
the Studio City and one time I was
running on the treadmill and I looked to
my right and the guy running next to me
on the treadmill next to me was Carl
Lewis and it's like what the hell's Carl
Lewis and the best part is I was going
faster than Carl Lewis like he was like
5.5 and I was a six-point but I was like
dust I was Ben Johnson Carl Lewis
without the roids and I did this whole
blog about this and rooms like that [ __ ]
was hysterical the Carl Lewis blog I
liked that situation and I when we did a
big meeting and I said I don't know what
kind of guy this is he runs really
intense I need an icebreaker and we
walking in rooms got a really cool
office corner office and everything and
if you walked to the window there was a
view of this of the restaurant soup
plantation you don't know if you know
soup plantation they have them there it
sounds terrible but it's a place that's
a salad bar with soup and I just said
like wow man I know you've really made
it when you got to view the soup
plantation like I took a shot yeah and
he just laughed and ran with it and then
we were off riffing so like if that had
fallen flat or if he was insulting or
something that would have been it
but we had the same sense of humor same
work I think I consider him like a
friend to this day how can you not I
mean I've worked here for eight nine
years yeah exactly right and how big was
it when you got there like the show was
a massive massive I mean it was it was a
sensation then he was like Rome had had
the biggest contract ever the most
affiliates ever he was on the ESPN
afternoon block at the time when PT I
was huge on the causative reinforcement
from his fans when you
guest host in the beginning or did you
have to kind of because they were not
you know like they were they would tell
you the truth big time it was hard I'm
in the first time I never hosted any
radio show on any level
I'd since in my fisher-price tape
recorder in like fifth grade and I
hosted the jungle
three hours single hosts no Baba Booey
no that's none of that it's just you and
you can't stop talking like no matter
what and I imagine Jim is so set in like
he does it the same way that how do you
not try and do it similar cuz you're
like that's what these people like but I
also have to be myself like that's a
mindfuck yeah the best I think the
easiest way was that I sat there and
watched him for like three years maybe
before I host the night so I could kind
of emulate him by giving it my own thing
I'll never forget like first show first
our first segment what is your take
what's the topic and you just pray for
the content gods to give you something
good and I pick some tear it was like a
Klitschko fight no one gave a [ __ ] about
Klitschko but it was my strongest take
so I loved with it and I think what
helped me is that most of the content if
even if they don't care about you they
care about making fun of you so at the
end of the first segment I read a stack
of emails about how terrible it's going
and everything and I can self deprecate
with the best of them like I know you
can so I survived somehow I remember was
it was Matt money Smith who's a prolific
radio host sure he told me a story once
the first time he hosted radio he's like
it was you know to our show and I had
about eight hours of content I was set
and 20 minutes on the first hour was
completely out of content I all up so I
came with like days and days yes oh I
used to do when I would do radio in
Louisville and I would go in there there
was one day where I almost overslept and
all my way and I was like not only have
I not prepared like I'm completely
frazzled yeah and it was the day that
LeBron bumped into Eric who was there
hex pulse yeah I remember that and I
went on and I'm in Kentucky and I went
John Calipari is gonna be the coach the
Miami Heat no straighter he's good and
then the full naalu up and I was like I
was so [ __ ] relieved but I have
churned through content so fast and
you're looking like I've done 12 minutes
like what the [ __ ] I have two and a half
hours left to go and I don't know about
you but like I talked really fast and
then when I'm nervous I talk like a
Ludacris beauty it's just a habit that I
have so you
you gotta just slow down man you got to
make that thing work and I didn't have
this seven he'd have my 10,000 hours I
had ten minutes you don't I mean I don't
know what I was doing and there was you
shouldn't it was like going from playing
stickball in the yard to like batting
third in Yankee Stadium there there was
no triple-a or single ASM I survived had
to make the transition a good morning
football easier though big time dude had
to yeah I mean it's good morning
football simple there's four of us I
don't have to talk that much right I say
my little bit about deck Prescott and
then Burleson drones on for 20 minutes
it's easy
I don't single hosts single host radio
you can do anything I know I don't know
if radio is considered a lost art or a
fading art I don't know but like those
radio hosts is Broadway man that's a
one-man show those are the most talented
people did you did you know good morning
football was gonna work right away hell
no no no the craziest thing about good
morning football in the short version is
it was conceived very rapidly there were
no auditions there was no chemistry test
when you make a new show maybe you have
one person that you know you're gonna
build around you do a series of
auditions and you do chemistry tests
where you put your known person with two
or three auditioners and you give him a
topic and you hash it out and you say oh
they have a connection right before we
were under contract and sitting down the
guy I had never met Kay Adams I never
met Nate Burleson I didn't know Peter
Schrager at all and it was like we're on
the NFL Network where everyone has a
gold jacket if they don't they have a
Super Bowl ring or Bowl and here's Peter
who's never plated down a football in
any level Kyle who didn't sniffed the
pros and Nate who was a really good
player but he's not Marshall Faulk or
LaDainian Tomlinson and then you had
case so like it was a terrible idea in a
lot of ways and I didn't know that I was
gonna even be on the show and so like
maybe two weeks before it even started
and I was living in LA with my newborn
baby and our toddler it was nuts man
absolutely insane
Wow yeah when did you realize this has a
chance I think for me I think it for me
was the first time I talked to Nate like
natives is this a different breed man
there's thousands it feels like a former
athletes new media and they're all great
some of them are great I knew Nate was
different when he told the story about
the first time when he was with the
Minnesota Vikings and they traded Randy
Moss
Naida at a thousand yards the year
before as the number two and he was like
on the way up star player in the making
and they came to him and they said we
traded Randy you're the number one now
and Nate's response was you guys are
crazy I'm not the number one I'm what
are you traded Randy That's not me now
every other player in the world
say the juju Smith Schuster's would be
this I'm ready
hashtag prepared for this rise up I'm
gonna be the number 1 Nate's initial
reaction was you guys are insane why
would you I'm not Randy Moss and so that
told me so much about him yeah team
player humble funny and the second
reason with Nate would you may relate to
is early on in our conversation when the
first chats ever had with him
he made a movie reference that was so
deep and so out there he referenced of
all things Teen Wolf to the sequel with
Jason Bateman Teen Wolf to t oo as in
Teen Wolf also and I was wearing shorts
at the time and I had pretty hairy
calves he's like damn man you let you be
in Teen Wolf too did you immediately
jump right over the Teen Wolf to make it
Teen Wolf too he's showing off and he
goes yeah I love Teen Wolf too so that
said I knew never mind the Randy must up
the second he can reference Bateman
being a boxer in a sequel to Teen Wolf
we're gonna go on you are a human
nostalgia machine I try to be
it's where like and the fact that your
own real world and had to be such an
accomplishment because of your love of
pop culture yeah that was insane I mean
I went to college when real world was
free college-age kids like the coolest
thing on television it was in when I was
in college was TRL weekend with corn
videos and and back street and I
remember getting into arguments about
what was gonna be number one on TRL was
are gonna be ja Rule holla holla
or was it gonna be that don't impress me
much by that insertion yeah yeah where
wasn't gonna be the bump up song by Tom
Green so that was the one Jesse camp and
all that stuff Terra was the coolest
thing and also on MTV so the the two
coolest shows were ever on MTV and then
if you include MTV Spring Break which is
amazing it was a top three so they real
world came to Princeton they did an open
call I wasn't one of the persons who
went on people who went out made a video
I got kind of drunk with a couple of
friends and just showed up to the open
call
and I remember I sat down and everything
was they had 50,000 people some want to
be on the real world and they try to ask
you unusual questions and see what
you're going and I remember the question
they asked me was and this is a little
different this is 2001 people talk
differently at the time they said say
you were to get be given a compliment
from a homosexual man that you were
attractive how would you respond to that
and I was like well it's happened twice
already today and I love this so I think
I would be just great with that that's
hilarious I think that they were you
know homophobia was they were being
routed out at the time and certainly
real worlds always been at the forefront
of that so like that was their big
question and I imagine they asked some
guys and they'd be like whoa I saw in
the one you did in Chicago like the the
theme of homosexuality was like a huge
part of that season yeah I mean there
was there was - we had to out cast mates
I guess they're called yeah it's Chris
and Anissa and like I mean it's been a
big part of that whole franchise back
going back to the beginning of also
worse yeah I mean it was like there was
cago gay pride was at the time and I
don't know now it seems everyday life
but it hasn't won it made a difference
and then I mean look my season is
renowned as the 9/11 season which is
terrible really yeah we were in the
middle of that while that all went on
which was just like the biggest mine
[ __ ] of all time being on camera while
that's happening so I mean real world
was insane it really was looking back on
it I'm 40 now yeah it was 22 at the time
what the [ __ ] was I doing the and the
whole time though you've always wanted
to kind of do sports though huh well I
wanted to be a movie star and that was
the way I did and then so you wanted to
be the movie star at the Lakers game in
the front row yeah she you really
weren't because I know you played
football and all that but your dream was
really to be Jack Nicholson yeah I mean
it was to be I mean it sounds strange
now but Tom Cruise people people say
like what's the movie that made you want
to be a movie star and you're supposed
to say some sort of I don't know Marlon
Brando back in the Sankei yeah like the
Daniel daily it was Jerry Maguire I saw
Jerry Maguire I'm like Tom Cruise the
coolest guy in the world in that movie
this is 96 before things got a little
eccentric with him and I'm just like I
want to do that's what I want to do I
want to fall in love with Dorothy Boyd
and I want to have little ray and make
jokes and then that propelled me to
doing it and days of our lives and stuff
and then when that dried up I always
feel
um sports was like my old girlfriend
from college that we never really made
it work and I ran into her at the
grocery store and I'm like oh you shop
here and then we got along and that was
it you had that one back and forth on
Good Morning football with I'm blanking
this morning funny running back that was
on Angela Williams yes yeah and what's
interesting is I've never shared this
with the 33-percent before when Sims was
here at a Super Bowl we had DeAngelo
Williams and we gave him 30 minutes
because I was like oh this guy can talk
yeah and he was insanely confrontational
which I loved because I it was after
happened with you yeah and he he said a
lot of things that upset Sims and then
when we got done he goes do you like
that and I said what do you mean he goes
oh I don't really feel that way I just
said that stuff and we never released
that episode yeah I wasn't a fan of that
I'm a very much a fan of people like
Martellus Bennett and people that
naturally think differently they came
cause conversation I'm not down for the
fake [ __ ] I don't know I don't play with
the fake [ __ ] did hear there's a
marketer did he apologize to you
afterwards or was that genuine when he
came for your neck like that no no I he
hasn't apologized and I'm not looking
for one for the record he there was a
moment on air when he was with Steve
Smith on a different program on the
network when Steve his former teammate
kind of called him out said like you
went too far and but it's fine the back
story and the D'Angelo thing yeah which
was very awkward and very unexpected
that segment before as you know
sometimes the guests listen to this
segment before we're talking about Gronk
and it was we were hyping Gronk like we
always do and hall-of-famer this Hall of
Famer that go to commercial hey
everybody DeAngelo Williams is here and
he comes out he goes I got some scores
to settle with you guys you guys don't
know what you're talking about with
Gronk and we're thinking great this
would be a great yes it's got something
to say so we get into this segment and
he's where it's going fine or ask some
of these questions and then it just
stops and DeAngelo's over here and
shraeger and i are on the other side of
the table and I'll never forget he
points at us with like a devil horns he
goes he goes like that you two which
I've never been pointed out like that's
weird he says you two and they went on
about that he had issues with us and
then the card came up the card of you
didn't play the game card and he played
it really really hard and we don't
appreciate it you haven't been through
what we've been through him and it's off
the rails I'll never forget when he was
kind of
but literally in my experience whatever
I remember in the teleprompter for the
next question it was like D'Angelo tell
us about the great work you're doing for
cancer research because he has an
amazing story about him in the pink hair
I mean it's really good and I wanna get
that question but we couldn't it was
really unusual and to answer your
question when the segment finally ended
he got up shook hands with Nate and like
stormed off and was very upset and
everyone's like what do you think that
was I was like I think he was trying to
make a name for himself and he was it
always felt to me like kind of an
off-brand Lavar ball like I'm gonna come
in and kind of play a character and
shake things up which I welcome gonna
shake them that way but it was like
really demeaning to the hosts it was a
weird day man so what we doin let you
know what's really interesting is when
that happened I turned to Sims and I
said it's the best thing that ever
happened to calibrate you think because
it's the elephant in the [ __ ] room
you just said you had a show on NFL
Network and it's you Peter Schrager Kay
Adams and Nate Burleson yeah and so in a
way instead of people going man what's
Kyle saying then that happens
cats completely out of the bag they see
how you respond and that you didn't just
go you're right you're right you're
right and I thought it level set the
show from then they're out I thought it
was the best thing that could have
happened to you it's a I mean if you
handled it well you know I mean if some
guys because then people are gonna oh
[ __ ] I didn't know that he played that
that many years in Princeton and had
that much success that he actually
played yeah oh like because I'm sure
like there was the Jim Rome level
there's the real world level sure I'm
sure you didn't want to talk about your
Princeton days I hate talking abut it in
a way it forced you to do it like I just
had spice atoms on and a lot of people
went [ __ ] spice atoms play in the NFL
that meme that I love that I play in the
NFL with her locker yeah hell yeah he
did yeah yeah I really thought it was I
knew it was gonna be good for you well
thanks for saying that I I makes me
break out in hives being on the NFL
Network talking about my football career
I mean I played for nine years I played
all the way through college was a kick
returner I was running back even talking
about now I hate because I'm on the same
network with LaDainian Tomlinson and
with Marshall Faulk or at least I was
and Kurt Warner and whatnot like I it's
very meager in comparison so I almost
never play that card but I guess I was
kind of forced to and that moment a lot
of people
bonded to the D'Angelo thing to the Kurt
Warner wants to come out of curtain to
the Jim Rome and Jim Everett ma
absolutely which was like I get asked
all the time was that stage was that
tell us about that it was well before my
time but like it was great for
television history absolutely was great
for Jim because he comes off looking
terrible in it I don't think so at all
he's on his back and Everett standing
over him with his vigor that he sat
there and looked him in the face and
called him Chris Everett and didn't back
down when he does his pictures where
he's holding a gun microphone or he's
like listen here and he goes into it it
adds credibility to it yeah if he would
have been like you're absolutely right
I'm sorry he could never play the tough
guy card again yeah when he says I bet I
do Chris I mean it's like holy and you
kinda didn't have a choice I know he
wishes he would have handled it
differently but I got the times times
that I've been interviewing someone
arrive like they punched me in the face
this could be pretty good I'm not gonna
try and be an [ __ ] yeah but let's see
if we can get it there do you like that
um I like do like I've thought about
having guests where like you come in and
I say hey man I'm gonna be right back
and like I just record the whole thing
and see how long you'll wait in this
room like I've had thoughts of that
that's funny because I like you I think
about creating content from home how do
I change everything like this table I
wanted like this shape because I want
scary people here to wear and you can't
see the [ __ ] cameras right now you
know I wear those things there yeah
there are they seen me sweat because
I've been sweating this whole time let's
go to that Christ um I have a sweating
problem to the point where Simms used to
make fun of me all the tighter to and
I'm not it's not about nerves it's just
that's my [ __ ] bow I know I heard
yeah that you would put maxi pads in
your armpits and would sit on an ice
pack
100 cent yeah what are your problem
areas my problem areas are my forehead
it just starts coming down and then like
it just starts permeating yeah and I
would say Pitts and then like back yeah
see there's lower back guys there's
Pitts guys I'm a pit guy and thankfully
I'm not too bad of a forehead because I
have a giant forehead it looked terrible
but when I start on good morning
football you
disconcerting it is to be doing live TV
to try to be delivering the best content
you can and some egg on Twitter's mean
like yo nice pit stains bro there ever
and I used to have oceans out yeah and
you're a handling Walker so there's good
and they're always up I'm not down doing
good right now
well I'll tell you why at one point
after I got made fun of so many times
and yes I would have our wardrobe worker
at take actual maxi pads and stuff them
into my shirt and tape them and so to
the point where like I mean if feminine
hygiene products are under my armpits on
TV it's pathetic Wow so finally I got
the same name Steve Smith the potential
hall-of-famer said dude you got to get
Thompson T's that's what cuz at Thompson
to you Thompson T is an undershirt that
has padding in the armpits that just
it's all just soaks it up they're like a
tractor beam how many Thompson T's to
you all not thousands thousands dude and
you know what the worst part is I hate
undershirts because it makes you feel
bigger right right and actually makes
you sweat more because we're into shirts
but it's all harness like in a canal
under my armpits do you see me sweating
rice to be on the soap opera and I just
I'd be a you know my the directors like
I like Kyle but we have to cut so much
for a Blokhin so my ability its bow
you're the one I always wanted to be
with and I know that you don't want this
moment to be and I would reach out and I
don't feel like the director Baek put
your hand on their face and then they'd
say cut can we get a fresh t-shirt and
this huge Lake Ontario is phoned up it's
not exactly sexy for the housewives at
home I had a major problem with it
Thompson T saved my ass that's
incredible but I still I'm sweating
right now I know people that have gotten
like injections into the boats hours
it's yeah people tell me I should get
that
Botox now I'm not wasn't not paying for
its come on what are we doing here that
just also doesn't sound healthy if your
body is supposed to sweat and you're
gonna call it it's gonna come out
somewhere else just get rejected back
into your internal organs now your
ankles are gonna be poor just the gum
and the damn that's funny man I also
heard that you might sweat if you saw a
raccoon terrified terrified of raccoons
then we all have our thing like sharks
sure everyone's afraid of sharks spiders
and then hi it's non whatever
raccoons scare the living [ __ ] out of me
because when I was a little kid there
was some that were in our chimney this
is the most morbid [ __ ] ever I don't
know if they do this anymore been the
80s there had been a nest in our chimney
when I was about to go down
start a fire and knock at that I would
have and that you would think we got an
exterminator and what they don't they
still do it they go into the base of the
fireplace and not a fire they release
like pneumonia or what's it what's that
what's the word ammonia ammonia ammonia
they flood their lungs no I release
ammonia up there and for some reason my
mom dropped the ball we were there
watching them do it and as the ammonia
goes up the raccoons are like yeah
they're making these walking dead sounds
that sound to the rest of my life will
haunt my dreams of the raccoons being
flooded with the ammonia and then
escaping through the chimney so scared
of them if one was in there right now
it's not it's not funny like I'm it's
not a cute afraid of it like I actually
would have a physical reaction like if
one came in right now you would get
behind me are you about to do this cuz I
know you guys are bringing it right
there let's see the sweat I mean it's I
mean it's it's disgusting right there
it's actually through the plastic so
your yours goes really yeah in a way you
felt bad for them but do you think the
shrink would say are you at a point now
where you fear the raccoons that they
maybe have talked to each other and they
have heard about the Brandt family
household in Chicago the Brandt massacre
of 86 lady said it was it's it's the
great outdoors that's right
back in the day that was my uncle you
ammonia and his ass and they all talk to
each you make the sound now Kyle
anything that's nocturnal is first a
little creepy the fact that's up at
night makes it ominous they're very
often rabid they're scavengers the
garbage all that crap it's any animal
that is gonna eat my rancid old
container of bacon or hummus what are
those in my crap I don't want anything
to do with them man no that's good to
know what your fears are in case I want
to prank you in the future if you bring
a raccoon in here yes I'm gonna need
Thompson Underpants too it did contain
myself what is your like of all the the
Jim Rome
good morning football so sports media
stuff you've done what was your favorite
moment to be a part of is there one that
jumps to you yeah there was an insane
one last summer the Chicago Bears let me
call a game on TV which was bat [ __ ] man
I hold on oh we got that Liev Schreiber
again know someone called me which
create let it know what's the music know
that you really like the show Adam Lefko
breaks up in a whole sweat the only
thing in his mind he's winning no so
what was the moment the Chicago Bears
last ring what happened at no Mitchell
Schwartz he just got a contract
extension way to go man congratulations
made the sports be with you I called the
Bears game last August and I mean on
television as the lead play-by-play guy
wow I was not color I was not the third
guy they called me in the spring said we
have five preseason games just playing
the Hall of Fame Game
and the fifth preseason game no one
watches no one plays we thought we'd do
something a little different with it
come in and just be yourself do what you
do on Good Morning football so I'm
sitting there in my childhood Cathedral
of Soldier Field well I've never called
a football game at any level you sit
down Jim Miller the former Bears
quarterback Corey Wooten another Bears
monster yeah and I have to call the game
and this is Tyler Bray of the Bears
versus AJ McCarron of the bills for
three hours in my hometown and like dude
I didn't know what I was doing I didn't
know that did you know all this stuff
there's a spotter that's next to you
so I'm stuffed what do you got so I did
the rookie sophomore NBA game on TNT
this year so it's like Donovan Mitchell
versus like Luca Donchev and I've talked
about this before where they hit me up
and they're like you know we're thinking
about having you do this you've done
play-by-play before I was like
absolutely I went to Syracuse University
and then like I hung up the phone I
called my agent I was like I've never
done it before you got a lie and and I
think it got back to them because then a
few weeks out they were like are you
sure it I was again I called up I an
eagle and I got like advice and he was
like this is how you should treat it
like the energy of it and all that yeah
but then when you sit in the chair and
it starts that's when you realize
is easier than doing a radio show in my
mind it was just we as museum it felt it
felt easy at the time because what you
just go back on is like you spent your
whole life watching exactly so you
watched whoever is Enberg and Musburger
and Nance and like you kind of just copy
them in your own way but as the
play-by-play guy there's so many nuts
and bolts do you have to hit my spotter
was incredible though so such an asset
you know like um I'm going Luca down
chick step back knocks down the triple
and then a little piece of paper comes
up and I go that's 12 points for Luca
John check this far kind of making that
case early for MVP hung guys and they
were talking and then like he puts like
another one in there and it's like oh
he's got six assists and I'm like how
the [ __ ] you keeping track of all this
that was Marv I had Marv Alberts
statistician oh my gosh and he was like
that was actually kind of fun really you
thought it was good he's like yeah I'm
sad you sound like you did better than
me
I remember there's a director who talks
to you through the whole thing and the
director will talk you through like go
to commercial there's this graphic and I
remember like in the third quarter
because they kept saying after the plans
he would say we're gonna go to the
replay and I kept going alright we're
gonna go to the replay every time and
then the third quarter he goes we're
gonna go to the replay don't say we're
gonna go to the replay let's take a look
that really what that is is I just came
up through traditional sports TV news
reporters were tanker people talking to
my ear all the time you're classically
trained I've in a way yeah yeah so like
I was able to do that but at the same
point like i-i've been DMing Danny Green
throughout the finals no way I guess he
was one of the guys I did the game with
and they had never done TV before was
him and Frank Kaminsky and I think I've
shared this story before that's a cool
idea we sat down an hour before the game
and Kaminski's eating meatballs and they
had never seen a rundown before and they
had never done television so we got out
there and I know how intros go and I'm
going Hayate up the AT&T Center where
the [ __ ] we were in his time for the
Rising Stars game and I knew exactly
they're gonna do so I was like it's Luca
Don chick and he pops on screen and I
remember Kaminsky looked at me he was
like he thought I magically brought that
video away because he had no idea of how
but I had the note
of what shots they were gonna go to and
so after like the first time out Danny
Green looks at me goes you're saving my
ass right now I go I got you bro like my
god this is gonna be easy so now like
I'm kind of rooting for Danny
let me tell because I went through the
game are you rooting for the Raptors
right now yeah of course I like
something different I'm rooting for the
Warriors why now they're the under I won
a Game seven
like so until we get to the game seven
I'll reevaluate who I'm rooting there
but I'm rooting for the Warriors to get
us to a game seven I don't know I'm
[ __ ] weird I like dynasties I like
dynasties too but right now I work for
the NFL I just want the shortest
possible outcome for the NBA just killed
the finals I I wish it was warriors and
four they went every game by 20 points I
want I don't want compelling content
coming in the NBA it's more people who
are watching them gosh so now this is
becoming one of the more compelling
finals of the decade and I hate it it's
not good for us I want blowouts every
single what's your favorite non headline
story in the NFL right now like I do a
thing here called whoa big offseason
which is all about the headlines that
are like not that big of a deal like you
hear Daniel Jones is a blender of Peyton
Manning and Eli Manning we're like the
third string linebacker that grew up on
a farm and he he chucked a lot of corn
and that's the toughness this Denver
Broncos team needs like that's the look
that's what we're in right now there's a
bunch Kevin white like yeah he's it
where is he now he's in Arizona like is
there a part of you as a Bears fan like
if you see like Kevin white might be
ready to hit that next gear in Arizona
you're gonna like [ __ ] I know big-time
what I'm saying that about now is the
bears kicker competition kick your
numbers just sounds so lame and so
tedious until you realize that like the
Bears have a serious [ __ ] problem and
that could cost them a Super Bowl run
their kicker
so Imber brought in his top five wolves
the week and I know one of the ones that
didn't even make the honorable mention
was the Bears right now are using
Augustus silence to find their kickers
no so instead of like everyone talking
[ __ ] or whatever the entire practice
field silence you can feel the Alpine
winds going through the dogwoods and the
cool waters of raised Creek and they're
shanking them they can't
they can't figure this out in Matt naggy
their coach is like the coolest guy cool
with the media sending a little tense
about this cuz all he gets asked about
is the kicker's they had three of them
yesterday three kickers and the Bears
just finished their bears 100 thing
so all these VIPs are here and there's
past great players and their families
and they're surrounding the field and
Negus alright let's bring the kickers
out let's do three kicks each from 42
yards first guy misses wide left second
guy misses wide right and third guy hits
the post just the post just like Cody
Park he did well one of them got cut
this morning and I think it's so big
because it's like um no Bears roster
with no kicker is like you have a
Bentley but you have no windshield
wipers if it rains you're screwed like
there's nothing you can do about it
they're not having a kicker could like
alter the whole NFC I'm fascinated by it
so you had to love as a lifelong Eagles
fan that double doing your to [ __ ]
love it that was I mean no like let's
really get it I'm and dad were fighting
I was at Cody parky kicking it and it
hit there and like I know it was blocked
but like you had to [ __ ] love that
how Kyle Brant
it was unbelievable man you know me do
it as a big-time Eagles fan I would grew
up in where would I grew up South Philly
I don't even know in Doylestown isn't it
incredible that parky Boyles town is
that where they're hard and so they
fight cigarette now it's just a random I
don't even know the towns I know that so
that later that huh
but I bet you were getting a lot of
tweets from Eagles fans being like I
think what was amazing about that was
the way that when Park he missed it he
like crossed himself before he even had
his moments like that dude is devout I
don't know about you I'm always very
jealous of people who have religion I
don't have much of it but I wish I had
it I think it's like very powerful I was
envious of that in that moment as his
whole life in world is crumbling he
still does that that was he as soon as
it but he does that and that means that
you know that he feels okay Williams
shielded imagine having that in your
life
I can't even pray with really committing
to it the ability in that moment to do
that honestly no it's like a random take
but that was the compelling moment
within that that Park he was and then
next thing and five days later he's
talking to Hoda
about that which was terrible but that
moment [ __ ] that was compelling to me
yeah so that was that was a man I was in
my underwear on my couch in the same I'm
very superstitious in the same spot and
it'll get blocked and I am
I do that stuff yes are you not
superstitious at all a little I mean I
think that's funny what's the position
and what's no it just it changes you
know 2002 playing the Bucs first half I
ate a chip at the start of every play
because the first play do Staley broke
out a long run and I ate a chip and my
friend looked at me and said we're go to
the store get more toasted oh yeah so
like there were 70 snaps in the first
half eight seven two chips I can't help
it that's my fiancee does not watch
Eagles games with me she I can watch NBA
games I can watch Sixers games like
Eagles games are the one that um that's
different
how the I get it for my dad the ocean
drop did you eat a chip what was your
reaction
that's heart-wrenching I was bad think
Nick Foles won that game I do well he
was in the oh no he was oh you mean if
he if the drive kept going yeah I think
he was gonna go finish that drive and
they were gonna win the game in the
Superdome and we'll never know there's I
mean I think that oh [ __ ] yeah but Roth
I don't get upset it off Sean because of
what he did the year before and when we
heard the injuries he was playing and
all that [ __ ] but at the time yeah that
was heart-wrenching for that's the
weight and that's really my my issue was
not out Sean Jeffrey's job my issue is
why did they run up to the line of
scrimmage and rush that play if if the
listeners remember back to that game as
I Locke was in their favor they didn't
need to also I don't want them to rush
because I don't want Drew Brees to get
the ball back right now and they were
right around the two-minute warning like
it was completely unnecessary it was the
opposite of what McNabb was doing at the
end of the Superbowl I really want you
to meet Deion Sanders I don't want to do
it I have so many notes here about it
and okay yeah but at the same point like
I had his album on ironically everyone
makes fun of Dion's album I bought the
album prime time at Best Buy in about
1994 I memorized the lyrics back in 89 I
signed the dotted line the first song is
called time for prime I was weighing her
I taped when he hosted SNL I taped it on
VHS Bon Jovi was the musical guest I
know every skit it was my hero worship
was beyond I met him I know that because
you have a long run with
Jim Rome that your takes are not safe
and that you can go in some interesting
directions you now I want to know how
many great rants or segments that you've
had that you have on the cutting room
floor that you can't do them good
morning football mm-hmm and is there one
that was really really good
maybe you know what we don't do we don't
go negative much yeah you know like we
don't rip players and teams that much
whereas like I rip owners and coaches
but I don't really because like in Rome
like if someone does something really
dumb like he could do an hour it's just
like telling that person over and over
and the listeners pour in so there is
some of that that took an adjustment man
I mean I'm especially simple some
high-profile athlete would let's say
bring a gun to the airport or get a DUI
and then just Rome is so good I'm
putting those people in perspective and
putting them in their Twitter is a
loaded gun yeah and it will go off it
will go up horse racing punched in the
face and a kick in the ass
like those are all the takes so I mean I
have a lot of them we have very amusing
commercial breaks where like in the
countdown we'll talk about something
that maybe wouldn't stay on the air at
all right but like I know where I am
there's a big-ass NFL shield on there
and like I'm not gonna tear into a coach
for five minutes but I guess we'd do it
sometimes I don't have like I'm trying
to think about the take that I held back
that I didn't do there's some things
sometimes you know what after the
D'Angelo thing
Le'Veon got on Twitter and also attacked
me it was pretty high-profile yes and I
wanted to fight back and two things one
just for my self-respect and two because
I think it'd be good for the show this
is a real as a superstar athlete you
understand marketing yeah let's do it
let's get some juice going here so to
speak and it did not happen because
that's I don't know it's like the kind
of atmosphere that we foster at the NFL
Network openly fighting with players but
I had some stuff I mean I I was ready to
go there are some drafts in your Twitter
right now a lot of drafts a lot of
drafts he cuz he came and he came back
tup D'Angelo and he made some really bad
metaphor about D'Angelo popped up on you
like toast and I'm just looking my chops
like dude you can run the ball better
million times better than me
know if you want to be in this with me
because I will tear you apart and since
then I root for a levy on and everything
like that but that was a time when like
I kind of wanted to fight and it was not
really a thing I I have in my notes that
you're a huge 90s MBA guy and as this
because of Jordan and like being a
Chicago fan you guys own the 90s and yes
I won the sports fan Powerball we joke
about the Philly thing I was living in
the Chicago suburbs in high school and
junior high when the six championships
were going on my dad used to take me to
the Chicago Stadium in the United Center
like Jordan was my everything and so it
became Dion but when I was a little kid
I he doesn't get any better than that
being living in Chicago I was five
minutes from their practice facility we
used to occasionally see Jordans car and
it would be like Jumpman 23 on the
license plate as a black Ferrari was
amazing so obviously you love Jordan but
of the sense the secondary cast who was
your favorite the second of the Bulls
are the NBA yeah were you like a Horace
Grant a Kukoc first guy I mean I love
the end of the benchers like I love Jeb
Bush leur I love Bobby Hanson I love
Bill Cartwright of course ugly shot in
NBA history if there's there's to be a
bleacher report article about the uglier
shots there might be already and the man
would shoot it like a baby doing a dunk
in a fisher-price hoop and yet he won
three rings as a starting center with
Michael Jordan Jordan used to always say
like there's this quote for him I think
might have been in the Jordan rules that
like he got so pissed off that he would
make these incredible baseline passes to
Cartwright and he would drop and Jordan
is eventually like if he drops one or
more of my passes I'm just gonna start
throw him in his [ __ ] face and I can
hit him in the face like that was Jordan
yeah when you would read that when you
were 13 you like you're the coolest guy
ever
man Carter I loved him all right so
you're a big 90s basketball Gally
you haven't met Deion have you met Tom
Cruise yet no I'm never met Cruz Thomas
Mapother the fourth or whatever was that
your that's your acting Deion Sanders he
was the guy like yeah he was the guy
that was I think I looked up to when I
was in high school in college but I
don't wanna meet him either you ever had
this experience like we talked about
this being disappointed at meeting
people I think we all know at this point
that Tom Cruise is not an another usual
guy right I don't think we would just
have a cool conversation like you and I
are having he's got some really
different interest than me yeah I just
want to leave them up there man like I
don't want to meet GI Joe either I don't
want to meet Hanson
like they would disappoint me if they
say if they were a dick or they didn't
think you were cool like I didn't have
to carry around the rest of my life I
want to leave Deon and maverick up there
you've seen through so much of this
industry like you've seen the [ __ ]
aspects of being a star on camera being
behind the scenes like what do you think
is the most real part of this industry I
mean the answer is the answer is just
like hard work like people who work
their ass off I'm not gonna pay you a
compliment you're incredibly well
researched I'm really flattered by how
much stuff you know about me because if
you do never help just now of course he
did he's alright so did Burleson's but
at least you have it like you do so many
interviews where you know the person
doesn't know who the hell you are yeah
you just know as a guest immediately and
I would say anyone who wants to get into
media the guest knows you don't know
about them didn't know your work so I
think the work and when I was working I
cameras burn on ESPN we had a very very
very very famous wide receiver come and
guest host the show and Jim Roma's
burning was all prompter it was like the
opening block was like a nine minute
prompter Reid and I wrote the script for
this guy and he said I said did you read
him are you ready
hey man you sure we're about to go live
on ESPN do you want to run through the
teleprompter a little bit no I'm good
I'm a game-day player let's just let it
rip and what ensued was nine minutes of
live television
that was completely nonsensical pictures
popping up of him not even talking about
things anymore the teleprompter operator
he's like should I go should I not it
was the worst debacle ever I can't
believe it's not on YouTube and I walked
up to him afterwards I go oh [ __ ] man
are you ready to move on yeah man I'm
ready we nailed it let's go and I was
thinking dude that is the worst segment
that's everybody SPN ever no work no
work ethic I met Chris Carter to still
be on it incredible and now he's in
first thing for it no it's not Chris
Carter it's someone just as famous as
Chris Carter though Keyshawn Johnson
it's not it's not Chris Carter Michael
Irvin no herbs incredible Ervin's
amazing yeah it's not urban okay but I
think one thing that I know your stuff
there's one thing I've realized
so I call my audience they now call
themselves to the 33 yeah this is cool
and the reason is is that when I lost a
co-host 33 percent of the shows equity
became available so I gave it to them
and they've really owned
and I think the cool thing is is that
when you can talk about the NFL but you
can also talk about life and people
probably see you and they see you on TV
in the morning and they go this guy's
got it made
he's got a beautiful wife he's got two
Healthy Kids he's good-looking he's had
all the success in the past but I know
that every day you're waking up and
you're going how can I be better than I
was yesterday or how do I achieve
something I haven't achieved yet and a
lot of people think that when you make
it you make it and so the thing I try to
pass along to them is whatever stage in
life they're going into I got a lot of
kids in high school I got a lot of kids
in college I got people that are
starting jobs and they're realizing [ __ ]
I don't want to do this mm-hmm and I try
to explain to them that you realizing
what you don't want to do is so valuable
because some people won't realize it
until it's too late
and you can be at this age where you can
pivot and so that was what was so cool
about your story was you're so deep in
the game that you probably pivoted at a
point where a lot of people around you
were going you sure mm-hmm
why are you gonna give this up yeah and
I'm sure that there was a lot of people
around you too that you getting off
camera hurt them more than it hurt you
because they couldn't then go that's my
cousin or that's my friend that's on
camera anymore and you're like no this
is my dream this is my life like I bet
you that was [ __ ] interesting too it
is it isn't if people sometimes ask me I
don't know what advice you have for
direction or anything like that and I
got I don't know I'm not gonna preached
any about anything other than I can say
that I had a few crossroads in my career
where like I really had no business
being in a certain room or doing a
certain job and I used to get insecure
about it when I met with your mom for
the first time and my resume was that I
had been on a soap star in a reality
show and now I'm gonna be a produce for
him I remember I said to him I said I
don't know my background is a little
different I don't know if you're gonna
like it which I shouldn't have said he
goes no man that's exactly why I like it
you know how many people I could find
who went to journal and you know are
writing a little bit and played high
school this and that he's like I want
something completely different
and I remember when I met about the NFL
Network job I said I didn't play I
haven't really been on TV since I was an
actor and I just said screw it
like there's no everyone's looking for
something different every way I think we
built up if you grew up like we did it
you have the right major in the right
internship and then the right
recommendation it can lead to your job
like a lot of that is just [ __ ] man
like it's just about having conviction
that I want to do this and like I think
I can be on a talk show and I know I can
write you some cool stuff about Kobe and
what he said about Shaq last night and
it will work on the radio and for some
reason they just bought it and I don't
know what the hell's next for me but
somehow I ended up here it's doing the
work that's what you said it's you go
there and you look around and you
realize what matters and then you just
do that harder than anybody else
mm-hmm and that's why you are where you
are and I hope some feel good yeah feels
really good but I know what you said too
like I'm completely unsatisfied like I I
don't I don't feel like yeah I'm set
I'll do this for next 25 years and
retire like it tears me apart that I'm
not still doing this and that I don't
have a book and I don't have a number
one pot I don't have any of that stuff
yeah but I mean I have two kids and I
have a pretty cool job so I try to rest
on that but it turns me apart well the
good thing is is that there's some
people that can get torn apart and then
they just stayed torn and there's some
people that they look back in their past
and they realize that every time they've
torn the best [ __ ] ever happens right
afterwards no you're right so what means
something greats about to happen to you
what was it you never you don't build
muscles unless you tear them yeah was
that Socrates was devious you I'm gonna
get that tattooed I think it was Donovan
Melendez the guy that changed me all
right yeah look at you man you've done
by yourself I had a good time
me too hope you enjoyed it this was
incredible open invitation yes never you
want thank you I want to get you innate
together sometime soon okay we'll wrap
together we'll do bars that's the cool
way to stall us out of here
yeah sure here we go all right stop
collaborate and listen haha she's back
on my brand new and bench hey something
grabs a hold of me tightly flows like a
harpoon daily and nightly will it ever
stop well I don't know turn off the
lights and I'll glow that's it that was
straight off the dope yeah to the
extreme I Rock a mic like a vandal on
stage makes a jump like a cut Wow the B
pick that goes complete freestyle right
there coyote I wrote out of my hand he's
sweating on the forehead now just like
me hit him up on social 33% let him know
that you appreciate it
y'all are the [ __ ] a holla holla hide
[Music]